okay this is um i don't want to spend a
lot of time on this this relates to the
bridge collapse in pittsburgh now at the
top of the show we already talked about
the hundreds of bridges just in new
jersey that have the same poor rating
as does as did the bridge in pittsburgh
that collapsed but i want to show you
just like the bottom
uh of the barrel
right wing opportunism on this in a
segment on fox news about the bridge
collapse fox host or anchor or whatever
julie banderas
said
this is what happens when joe biden
talks and talks about an infrastructure
bill and doesn't get anything done now
of course joe biden passed the
infrastructure bill but julie banderas
apparently didn't know that notice also
that everybody on screen is just kind of
nodding along you've got kaylee mcinanny
you've got arbiter of ideas dave rubin
and others take a look at this fairy
tales i love fairy tales i mean but um
normally i only enjoy them when it's
during a bedtime story in the evening
not on a daily basis for the past year
since the white house has been overrun
by democrats but president biden has
been making promises over promises over
promises and as you've noticed none of
them have come true and when a president
makes promises and then doesn't deliver
and then something like this where a bus
i mean there could have been multiple
casualties so thank god nobody was
killed but honestly a bridge collapsing
right before he's back in june of 2021
he started talking about his bipartisan
infrastructure deal there's nothing
bipartisan about it if it if it was
bipartisan it would have been passed by
now so clearly he's not getting the
message across to the other side of the
aisle which by the way if you remember
during his campaign he said that he was
going to be the president that was going
to reach across the aisle that he was
actually going to make um policy and you
see kaylee mcinanni there nodding along
now that infrastructure bill did pass
the bill passed um months ago it passed
in november and it was bipartisan in
that 19 republican senators and 13
republican representatives voted for the
bill
later julie banderas
tweeted that quote tweeted that she
misspoke now she's since deleted the
tweet because the tweet is so stupid but
her explanation was quote i misspoke i
was referring to the president touting
the bipartisan bill back in june and
here we are today and nothing has
improved hence the bridge collapsed uh
now it was so stupid because it takes a
while to actually get that money and get
contracts and distribute it her
criticism was about joe biden and the
passage of the bill now she's saying the
criticism's actually that that bridge
wasn't yet fixed but biden obviously is
no more to blame for that than the fact
that trump had four years to do
infrastructure and didn't the bridge
problems are major problems the
infrastructure problems are a disaster
i've been talking about it on the show
for a decade there's no question about
that
but the initial claim and the criticism
and then the explanation it's all
completely bogus like this is really
the worst of trash politics she makes a
statement b
based on completely
they're not wrong facts they're it's
based on lies
she takes the statement back but says my
general analysis was still good and it's
considered a correction but it's so
stupid that then she deletes it like
this this is really the worst of the
worst of the worst and unfortunately you
know you've got these bobble heads on
fox news their heads on a swivel nodding
along even kaylee mcinanny who has to
know
has to know that the bill had already
passed and it passed months ago and it
passed with republican support as well
this is another one of those examples
where you quite literally will have
brain rot if you just listen to the
analysis they put out and you believe it
yeah joe joe biden's to blame because he
never passed that bill well actually he
did pass it
he did pass it and it you know takes
some time
uh to get things done but what about the
four years trump had
during which he said he was going to do
infrastructure and he didn't well this
is where we end up